- Oh, my gosh!
I like your shoes!
- Thank you very much!
- Yes!
- I got all dressed up for you.
- I like it. I like it.
How are you doing?
- I'm great, thanks.
- You're doing great?
- Well, I feel like it's only proper
every time I have someone
here from Downton Abbey
that I have high tea.
So Justin...
(Allen and Kelly laughs)
I think it's just proper. It feels wrong.
It feels wrong unless I have it.
- Look at this.
- Look how careful you are carrying that.
You were like, I will not drop this.
- And then the bow and then bow.
- Hit it, Justin.
- The bow... oh, he didn't bow.
- Yeah, he didn't bow. He
didn't like us that much.
- Fired!
(Kelly and Allen laughs)
So we have all these things for you.
- Wonderful.
- Cakes and everything.
- Are you going to have tea?
- I already have tea.
As you can tell, allergies
are trying to kill me, Allen.
- Right.
- But congrats on the movie.
- Thank you very much.
(audience claps)
- Yeah. Yeah.
So this is also congrats to...
it's baby number two almost, right?
- Baby number two.
- Are you ready?
- Thank you.
I am ready. You know what?
I'll take this in a minute.
I am ready.
The one thing that I've
noticed with baby number two
when you're preparing the room
and building all the stuff.
- Yeah.
- Now I have a little person
going, what you doing, Daddy?
No, oh yeah, I'm just building this.
I'll help you.
No, no, I'm okay.
And then suddenly all the
little bits go missing,
you know the bits to put them together.
- Yep.
- So yeah, she did that the
other day which was fun.
- Is she doing that fun
thing that my eldest did
when my son was born and it was like,
hmm, time's being taken
away from just focus on me?
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh yeah, oh yeah. Yeah.
She's doing that definitely
and anytime that it's brought up,
suddenly she's on the bump,
kind of lying on it going,
what was that? Talking about me or this?
Oh, it's okay and kind
of covering it, you know?
(Kelly laughs and claps)
- I love that. I love that.
So speaking of your wife, you posted this.
(whooshing sound)
- [Jessica Herman] These are
my favorite group of pictures.
- [Reporter] Like thousands of other fans,
11-year-old Jessica Herman
has transformed her bedroom
into a DiCaprio shrine.
- [Kelly] Winnie-the-Pooh!
- [Jessica] I have the
biggest crush on him
and that he's very cute
and he's the best actor ever in Titanic.
(whooshing sound)
(Kelly laughs and audience claps)
- I love this!
So this is my favorite
thing we've ever shown.
That DiCaprio fan
interviewed was your wife.
- My wife, yeah, on Extra
when she was about 11 or 10.
I'm in so much trouble.
- Oh my God!
No but it's amazing!
Like you said that she may
divorce you after posting it
cos it's so great though.
- It's great and you know what?
Yeah, I did. She didn't divorce me.
I did maybe spend a couple of extra nights
in the spare room.
- Yeah.
- I just love the fact that
it's Winnie-the-Pooh and Leo.
Kind of-
(Kelly and audience laughs)
It's definitely like, it's
transition of a young girl.
- He does look like, as a boy,
he could have played Christopher Robin.
I'm just saying.
- He could still.
He's that good.
- He's that good. He could
still play Christopher Robin.
- A man version.
So we're all very excited
for the new Downton movie.
- Great.
- So when did you realize
that the show had become
as huge as it did?
- I think it was the first
season had come out in the UK.
Hadn't come out in the States yet
and I was back in Ireland doing a play.
So I'd missed all kind of the big...
everyone talking, all the buzz.
- Yeah.
- I was on the Tube on
the underground in London
going back to meet all the
cast to watch the final episode
and I got on and I noticed
the whole carriage went-
(Allen makes shoosh sound)
And someone very unsubtly went,
the driver, the driver.
(Kelly laughs)
And everyone was, oh yeah, it's the driver
and then okay, it's kind of weird.
Got off and-
- And my character has a name.
- Yeah, it's Tom. Tom Branson.
(beep sound)
- I am more than the driver.
- But it was really bizarre
and then I walked out of the of the Tube
and was just walking down the street
and about 10 more people
were like driver, driver.
- Oh my God.
- Like all I'm missing
is the car, you know?
(Kelly and Allen laughs)
- That's amazing.
So, what your character
was only supposed to be in a few episodes.
- Three episodes in the first season.
- Yeah, they loved you that much.
- Well, I don't know,
but I think it was Julian
Fellowes, the writer decided,
I've got some good ideas
with the Irish character,
the chauffer and the lady of the house.
- Yeah.
- So yeah.
- I'm glad that the ideas were there.
- So am I!
(Allen laughs)
- Yeah. I mean, not just for
you but for us. We love you.
- Aww, thank you.
- Yeah.
(audience claps)
- So now, focus of the new movie.
How crazy is that?
It's different now, right?
- Yeah. I mean, it was great.
My character went through
like a lot of heartache
and heartbreak and the movie
opens with his wedding.
No spoilers cos it's in the trailer
but it's great that my character
finally finds happiness.
which is something that
I really wanted for him
and I think he deserved.
- Yeah. Agreed. Well, it's
time for a quick break.
Everybody, Downton Abbey, A
New Era, is in theaters now.
Everybody should go see it.